30 % des français seraient tentés par
l'abstention au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle dimanche 10
avril ce serait un record dgo
protestations des intérêts l'abstention
au premier tour progresse doucement
depuis près de 60 ans pourtant dès 1965
date de la première élection
présidentielle de la vème république la
télévision diffusé des spots
publicitaires pour inciter les français
à aller voter
alors premiers mois de pas oubliée chére
premiers mois
mais malgré ces spots plein d'entrain
l'abstention progresse doucement lors
des premiers tours des élections
présidentielles 15,2 pour cent en 1965
21,6 % en 1995 et le record actuel lors
du premier tour en 2002 avec une
abstention de
28,4 pour cent abstention qui entre
autres permet à jean marie le pen de se
qualifier pour le second tour
il hier encore l'abstentionniste
s'ébroue et insouciants sur la plage de
palavas aujourd'hui l'ambiance comme la
mer il y est plus ajouté
s'abstenir c'est celle à l'apparat
n'importe quoi vous culpabiliser non
mais je vais me responsabilise
c'est à dire c'est à dire voter au
deuxième tour
2002 marquera les mémoires cinq ans plus
tard au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2007 l'abstention
chute à 16,2 pour cent mais les
mauvaises habitudes reviennent et de
nouveaux l'abstention lors du premier
tour remonte pour atteindre 22% en 2010
est pour le premier tour à venir
l'abstention est estimée à 30% avec
l'épidémie de covin 19 et la guerre en
ukraine la campagne présidentielle a
bien du mal à s'imposer dans le
quotidien des français le refus d'aller
voter continue également d'être brandie
comme une arme de contestation par de
nombreux électeurs désabusés
[Musique]